radar système qui utilise les ondes
radio pour détecter la présence d'objets
et déterminer leur vitesse ou arme
antichauffard redoutable dans les
ivelines près de 600000 procès verbaux
ont été établis en 2012 un palmarès
record qui nous place en 5e position
national les flash au feu rougge
propulsent le département sur la
troisème marche derrière les BOUCHES DU
rhô et le Val de Marne de radar
hivlinois se classe dans le top 100 des
plus actifs en France le plus redoutable
trône le long de la RD 85 avenu des
États-Unis à Versailles plus de 46000
flash comptabilisé l'année dernière soit
128 crépitements quotidiens celui qui le
talonne se situe sur l'autoroute A12 au
niveau de bli dans le sens trappe Paris
36400 flash enregistrés en 2012 soit 100
par jour conséquence une progression du
nombre de stagiaires pour la
récupération de points devenu précieux
80% des infractions constatées c'est de
la
vitesse ensuite vient le feux rouge qui
monte en puissance dû à l'automatisation
des des contrôles les feux rouges
automatiques le téléphone on observe une
montée en puissance du du téléphone tenu
à la
main l'alcool ne venant que que
pratiquement en fin de pleuton mais
selon ce professionnel la plupart des
excès de vitesse ne ferait perdre qu'un
point la mortalité sur les routes
françaises diminue depuis quelques
années 203 personnes ont perdu la vie le
mois dernier contre 277 en mars